tu veux bien me dire pourquoi je refuse
de t'inscrire au club Barbier Rachel
est-ce que c'est des poupées déversée
par des enfants orphelins et victimes de
la mondialisation
on est première c'est toi
et aucune de ses amis arrivés c'est
quand même un peu inquiétant ce côté
Valérie tu veux dire oui
c'est très gentil de sa part mais ça
pourrait déranger sa maman pourquoi tu
la laisses pas dormir chez sa copine
dans les fesses
et son soutien-gorge
moi je suis amoureuse de ton père
j'ai demandé coller ton mariage le jour
où j'ai goûté ses boulettes tellement
bon en plus
votre mari
parce que son couple vieillit moi je
suis lucide